clark county leaders are planning for  the future right now and they want your  input they're asking what you want to  see here in our community  over the next 30 years anything from  recreation to development  they will use your comments and your  concerns as they update the county's  master plan  it hasn't been updated since 1986.  you can imagine the population was just  over 500 000 back then  and that now we're at uh 2.3 plus  million  people and you know the strips  completely changed our suburban areas  have completely changed  and so this is really a great  opportunity to look forward for the next  three decades kind of looking forward  through 2050  and decide what what our community wants  to look like  so far they've heard concerns about  growth expanding transportation services  and rising housing prices  you can weigh in right now through  saturday there's a survey on  transformclarkcounty.com